[Music]
hello in a very warm welcome indeed to
quadriga coming to you from the heart of
Berlin and this week our focus is on
Russia where the former KGB agent bloody
Mir Putin has just been reelected to a
fourth term in office that victory
though comes at a time when tensions are
running high between Russia and the West
with the UK and others accusing Moscow
of being behind the poisoning of the
former Russian double agent sergey
skripnikov costume will there be a
further escalation of the crisis our
question here on quadriga this week
Putin re-elected a toxic presidency and
I've got three guests here in the studio
to discuss that question beginning with
DWS
own Christian tripper a senior
correspondent who has in recent years
been based both in Kiev and Moscow
christiana argues that it's wrong to
demonize Vladimir Putin and don't
appease Russia he says start planning
for a post
in Russia also with us is Alan posner
commentator for the Berlin Daily
developed Alan believes that Putin not
only poisons his enemies his army of
internet trolls is poisoning the
political atmosphere in the West his aim
is to paralyze democracy and a warm
welcome to - Gemma pert skin' a
freelance journalist an expert on
Eastern Europe Jemma says it's always
the same reflex whatever happens it was
always Moscow
I'd like to begin with you al-anon now
note the EU says its shocked by quote
the first offensive use of a nerve agent
in Europe since World War two are you
shocked Alan no I'm not shocked I'm
disgusted
it's stupid to say you're shocked
because this was going to happen sooner
or later a couple of years ago mr. Levin
Yanko and other Russian x-pyr was who
blows blew the whistle on mr. poutine
was poisoned with polonium in London so
that was if you will a nuclear weapon
used against Britain and now they've
used chemical weapons against Britain so
no I'm not shocked
I might just think this this is the face
of Russian imperialism the face of
Russia the leaders of the UK the US
France and Germany have come out with a
joint statement condemning the nerve
agent attackers an assault on UK
sovereignty and saying it is high and
saying it is highly likely Russia was
behind it you say Russia always gets the
blame you see you don't see you seem to
be doubting that Russia is to blame I
think it's too early to judge because we
didn't have any proof so far I think
it's very clear that one needs to have a
statement of solidarity because
different from your point of view I was
shocked and I think a lot of British
people in Salisbury were shocked that
something like this could happen in
their country and I find it quite
understandable that is a difficult
situation for me you need to react
somehow but I think it would have been
much better to wait with blame second
but if you say that Russia always gets
the blame why does Russia always get the
blame I find that there's a certain
stereotype of Russians as it's often
said and in British media and even
British politicians there should be much
more differentiation between what is the
Kremlin what is actually if certain
networks we don't know in in in the
secret service and I think one could but
shouldn't be so fast
because
sometimes it's very just the country of
what you want because especially because
it was because before the elections I
think a lot of people in the Kremlin was
quite happy to show that we are blamed
again and to have a certain atmosphere
which makes a lot of Russians feel that
we are always blamed without any proof
what do you say create I mean the
Russians will surely say why would we do
this in an election year why would we do
this at election time good question I
would like to add to comment on what
Jemma just said there's an another
typical pattern of how Moscow reacts
whenever things like that referred to
the fate of mr. Litvinenko was poisoned
with polonium some 1012 years ago look
at what happened in eastern Ukraine when
the Malaysian airliner mh17 was shot
down killing 300 passengers it's all and
meant there's a lot of evidence that a
russian-made missile shot from the plane
down and Russia always reacts in the
same pattern it's foreseeable it's
there's nothing new in it and this
happens again right now claiming that
they didn't do it
accusing others and refusing to accept
an international expertise of the whole
process there were voices from Russia
two days ago the deputy foreign minister
which is not yet the official position
of Moscow or the Kremlin but the deputy
foreign minister said that Russia will
not accept what the UN watchdog for
poisoning gases will find out they were
not accepted whatever the fine Christine
the question was why would Russia do it
now why would they do it it's election
time why would they do it in the
build-up to the soccer world cup which
is such a showcase occasion even in
danger the soccer world cup I mean we
have calls from Great Britain Boris
Johnson the Foreign Secretary who wants
to boycott the tournament and wants to
get the whole European Union into by but
why do Russians do it or it's
speculation I mean you've got read it in
the papers but Russians always unite
behind their leader in a very strong in
a very nationalist way where
they feel being attacked or aggressed
from outside from other nations why now
if Russia is behind this attack why have
they launched it now Alan I still I
still don't understand um well you
really ought to ask mr. Putin that or to
not but Stalin once said Stalin who
created the organization for which mr.
Putin worked as a young man from whom he
learned everything that he knows about
starting what said of even the terrible
that people the only thing that people
remind remember of even the terrible was
he dealt with his enemies and he was
feared and that's what remember of
styling and that's what Putin was to be
remembered for he deals with his enemies
and he is feared by them and why do it
before the election because the reaction
of the West was of course foreseeable
and he could use it on the one hand we
on the one hand people who admire mr.
Putin will say ah he deals with his
enemies like they did were starting like
they did with Yvonne the Terrible and
people who don't agree with mr. Putin
will come and say how we're being
attacked again
so we'll vote for the strong man who
supports Russia it's a win-win situation
for him and there's no way the West
cannot run into that trap because either
we do nothing and prove once again that
we are weak or we react with strong
words and say what's the truth that
Russia is behind this and then people
accuse us of always singling out Moscow
we always single out Moscow please
happens to be Moscow who does all these
terrible things I find this kind of
pattern of thinking very dangerous
because it's very much a Cold War
thinking and we live in a very different
world my thinking is dangerous poisoning
people is dangerous I mean that's for
sure that poisoning people is dangerous
but still I think it would be helpful to
really to see Russia not always as a
continuation of the Soviet Union which
it isn't is even if there are certain
things happening where there could be
the
the Kremlin is behind it I wouldn't
exclude this but I think it's very
important also for British people that
you have more in your hands than the
British government had and I mean we
have only now people coming in really
looking into this thing and in about ten
days we will know what it is about okay
one thing we do know that we there's
still a lot of work to do to clear up
the crucial details on the attack on
Sergei script as we've already mentioned
of similar poisoning and poisoning
incident back in 2006 here's some images
these images show 66 year old former
Spicer geese creep all in a supermarket
just hours before he and his daughter
Yulia were attacked in Salisbury with a
nerve agent Nova chock it stirred up
memories of Russian agent Alexander
Litvinenko who was murdered back in
November 2006 his tea was poisoned with
radioactive polonium an inquiry into his
death said it was likely Putin had
ordered the assassination Litvinenko's
widow also accuses him it was message
very serious Russia Russia stayed behind
of this crime
I don't like we need to wait for another
death to understand what we have to do
is there a pattern to these attacks
[Music]
christiana is there a pattern to the
attacks is there a bigger scheme here a
broader scheme like it looks like a
broader scheme and of course the
evidence is that the Russian state or
corporate structures of the state are
behind it but now I go with Gemma we
don't have the final proof there's a lot
of evidence but if you carefully look at
this joint declaration of the four
powers addressing this crippled case the
Allies the British allies they give full
solidarity to London but they don't buy
the argument that the Russian government
is behind it what Ross Johnson's and
others claim so the EU and the u.s. they
take a rather cautious stance and it
took the government in London some two
days to convince Paris and Berlin to
subsist to sign this paper and we have
an EU summit now and the you fall short
of of new sanctions it's also very
cautious and measured Christian but the
fact is that if they do have a case and
if Putin's Russia if Putin was behind
this then what this amounts to is surely
state-sponsored terrorism it is yeah but
there is no proof behind it and this
always has to be seen and taken into
account
look there's a Russian expert on
chemical weapons who as proof positive
that this Russian state wasn't behind
this said if we had been behind this the
man would be dead already
and this is the kind of cynicism we have
to deal with you having been in Russia
Iran so also know that the whole of kjb
slash corporate private terrorism even
down to Chechens operating somewhere in
the in the south of Russia that that
it's a whole continuum of a continuum of
power but in the end if Putin wanted to
stop it he could if he can't it's almost
even worse so the fact is we have a
Russian state surrounded
by terrorist agents who even who
possibly act on their own account in but
it's in order for the Kremlin to have
plausible deniability but the fact is
there is a power center there which
employs terrorism as a matter of course
against its enemies in Russia and
outside Russia and this is what we have
to deal with and and the whole point of
this vagueness is to make inquiries
almost impossible as you said Russia
denies the International conclusion that
they shot down the Malaysian Airlines
flight over the Ukraine Russia to this
day denies the give the conclusion of
all people have ever investigated it
that they killed Litvinenko there's to
this day no one has pointed the finger
at the real murderers of Anna
Politkovskaya and mr. Nemtsov opposition
politicians in Russia this is the point
of Russian security it's it's opaque it
can't be found also I mean I'm quoting
here from Newsweek 14 UK police and
British Secret Service are re-examining
the sudden deaths of 14 people with
connections to Russia that were
previously dismissed by authorities as
natural how much of a crisis is this
then between the west and Russia this
must be the worst crisis since the Cold
War I wouldn't agree I mean one thing I
have a problem with this kind of terms
of the West I don't know what this would
be today because I'm very much a person
who thinks that the cold was over I grew
up in the Soviet Union as a German child
and the times of the Soviet Union on of
the Cold War and I think it's very good
to get rid of all this terms and this
understanding and really see the world
differently today and I would very much
opposed the picture mr. Posner showed us
about Russia today because it's
difficult for people like like me who
know Russia to argue because I mean that
nothing to excuse I mean the the auditor
authoritarian regime of poutine there
are very strong KGB structures but still
it's it's a country which needs our
understanding in that way that we need
really to look into the into different
say trade in what is going on there and
we don't really know who was behind this
attack
they're also the killing of Nemtsov it's
not clear I don't think that it was in
the interest of Putin on his birthday to
get killed and I mean a lot of experts
now about this chemical weapon and a lot
of interpretations but I would really
think we should wait for the facts and
if it's the way mr. Posner said then
then we need direct because we've met
we've mentioned the the Boris Nemtsov
killing our DW colleague Shannon M sofa
the daughter of Boris Nemtsov actually
spoke to the British Foreign Minister
Boris Johnson about the script I'll
attack let's listen now to what he had
to say Boris Johnson and then a comment
from blood of important and then we will
come to you Christi and I promise after
Putin you also have to consider that
circus group al the guy that they
attempted to assassinate is somebody
who's been identified as a target for
liquidation and that Vladimir Putin has
himself said that traitors ie defectors
such as mr. screech ow should be
poisoned so it's a a Russian only nerve
agent and it's finished we destroyed our
chemical weapons under the supervision
of an international watchdog we were the
first to do it our partners also
promised to but didn't keep their
promise
yeah we had Boris Johnson there
indicating that he believes that
Vladimir Putin does order the killing of
traitors and defectors as he sees the
actual language that he's approaches
opposed to have use traitors will kick
the bucket he says this doesn't sound
like the kind of man that one can reason
with Christian so the British government
now is investigating a reinvestigated
fork team investigating 14 cases
unsolved cases of dead Russians in
London but I think we have to ask why
the scrip our case now came as such a
wake-up call some of these cases are
nearly twenty years old why didn't the
British government pay attention to
these cases before you know well yeah we
have to see that this is an ailing
government and government under immense
pressure who has to deal with brexit and
can't cope with the brexit obviously and
no one can and now they make Russia a
scapegoat
this is I mean politically speaking this
is obviously the opposite lanes no the
opposite is true I'm sorry Christian the
the point is these cases were not
identified not investigated fully
beforehand because Russian dirty money
is so important in London yeah I mean go
through places like Knightsbridge
Chelsea and so on every second house it
belongs to some Russian oligarch when
and so on so there were you know London
is the center of money from Russia and I
think that's the main reason why
hitherto
Britain has been rather lacks in
negotiating now finally as you say it's
a wake up call
now finally these cases are being
investigated not because Britain is in
the middle of brexit but because but the
finally they're waking up to the fact
that they have been too dependent on
Russian money as Germany for instance is
dependent on Russian gas we've all been
much too negligent with regards to this
imperialist power do you do you really
expect the British government to address
this question of dirty of laundered
Russian money and to cut back some some
of it well I think this might finally
happen
yes and also there still the question
how do you deal with with Russia now I
think one needs still to think I mean
because we saw there was a big victory
of Putin now and we will live with Putin
for the next six years so there I think
we still need a common policy on this
where we can't only focus on incidents
like this but it need also to develop a
certain strategy yeah absolutely being
cautious I think we agreed on this and
to see certain dangers which which are
in in this government but but still I
think with this very black-and-white
picture we we are not prepared enough to
have it's not a black-and-white picture
because black and white picture would
paint us as purely white but it is a
black picture when it comes to Putin's
imperialism and butene is not the whole
of Russia and well not all policies you
just said he had an enormous victory was
70 percent I mean it's like it's not
quite Soviet you know style that would
have been 99.99% but it's huge and it's
huge because he didn't have any real
opposition sure no we agree on this I
mean it was yeah okay so so I'm what I'm
saying is this is another authoritarian
government which for at least 10 years
has been constantly aggressive against
the West and think of Georgia think of
the Ukraine think of Syria and think of
these attacks and that think of the fact
that Russia supports every right-wing
extremist party in Europe the fpr the
free freedom party in Austria which is
now in government controls the defense
and foreign ministry is a client of
Moscow Jobbik a fascist party in Russia
is a client of Moscow the new fascist
party in Italy is a client of muscle the
fallenness Journal in in France is a
client of Moscow's and the AFD in
Germany the right-wing party has
excellent relationships with Moscow
how much more has to happen before we
say we may not be white but they're
definitely black so one question is how
long we have to deal and to live with
mr. Putin there was a tweet of one of
the the editors of the Russia state
propaganda news so-called news outlets
and she indicated that mr. Putin might
serve as lifetime president for Russia
so Russia following the Chinese example
but what what I wouldn't want to do the
question I want to raise is there's no
scenario in Russia of how to hand over
power to a successor
there's no successor but you're looking
far too far into the future Cristian I
mean let's begin now those of there I
want to come back to the soccer world
cup because it is a major global event
and I my guess is that Vladimir Putin is
going to go on a charm offensive in the
next couple of months ahead of that
event he's going to come docking at
Western doors how should the West
Jemma's not happy with the term in
itself but how should the west if we
want to use that term respond of course
and the West has to open the door and
for example tried to improve the
situation on the ground in the Ukraine
this is I think the only way and get a
bit further in this completely stalled
peace process there and there is a
window of opportunity in international
politics right now because mr. Putin
wants this tournament he wants to be the
host of many nations and one the
poisoned former spy becomes a footnote
of history no not a footnote of history
but in lay I'll prolly take what else
shall Western leaders do they're now
trying to grasp that chance if it's
there and start seriously renegotiating
what is on the table between Russia and
us it's not realistic I don't think
that's realistic and I think we
shouldn't play his in his cards because
that's what we do you do with a position
like mr. Posner has and also if we look
at the British Russian relations now we
have 23 diplomats and out there and
there and for I was very sad to hear
that the British Council will be closed
which is an important institution for a
lot of people in the
civil society in Russia and also the the
football match will be a unique
opportunity of people to meet to travel
to Russia to see that it's very
different from the stereotypes mr.
Posner is presenting tonight mr. Posner
is getting very impatient as well you
know people travel to Russia and they
won't see the real Russia just as they
didn't when they came to 1936 to the
Olympic Games in in in in Berlin and if
necessary everything we spruced up and
you won't see the secret police of
course and so come on the idea that by
visiting each other you get to
understand each other the people's bla
bla bla bla let's look and it's gonna
understand one thing you are comparing
the 1936 Olympic Games and the way
Hitler used and abused that sporting
tournament you're comparing it with the
way the flood emir putin will use
promoting the soccer world cup that's
absolutely right into the Boris Johnson
light on this I'm not buying into any
line and I'm not comparing poutine with
mr. Hitler for several reasons but and
what I'm saying the sporting events are
used for propaganda reasons I'm giving
one example which we know sitting here
in Berlin where that happened in 1936
and we all know the soccer world
organization FIFA is incredibly corrupt
there's lots of scandals I mean the the
tournament in Qatar is is is a scandal
and the tournament in in Russia was a
scanner and I don't know who bought it
but it's time to buy out of that and say
we're not gonna reward authoritarian
regimes or rich Arab sheiks or whatever
with tournaments like this once and for
all
let's stop this ok we're running out of
time Christian your comment in respect
long way I mean there is some bla bla
bla and there is some mythology about
how fruitful such an event can be for
politics but if you give up chances like
that I mean what world would we live in
many iron curtain separating nations
from nations what will you do with China
no more business with China anymore
they're not talking about business
that's that's no no business
in general be culture be it sports
believe the exchange of youth no Jamaat
the final comment yeah I think we can't
paint the the world and and the colors
we would like we need to live with
politicians we have with countries we
have and this is really difficult I mean
I think we agree on a lot of more things
than we heard today because I wouldn't
like to portray you've put in all the
government nicely but I would like to
have a realistic approach okay we're
gonna have to go there Jemma Putin
reelected a toxic presidency that's been
our question this week on quadriga
thanks very much for joining us bye-bye
and truths
[Music]